okay another question that came in David
a Joe Biden is expected to select his
vice president around August 1st who do
you think would hurt Biden the most so
earlier another one was it last week I
said that I believe Elizabeth Warren
should be Joe Biden's vice presidential
pick this is a different question not
who would be best but who would be worst
so the first thing is to understand what
is the goal of selecting a vice
president there's essentially two goals
one don't cause a problem for the
presidential candidate so Sarah Palin
did not help John McCain back in 2008
now McCain was already losing but Palin
was a cartoonish sideshow and certainly
did not help and number two can you
increase the electorate can you bring in
some additional people to bolster
support for the presidential candidate
so you look at someone like Paul Ryan
Paul Ryan didn't do much one way or the
other for Romney in terms of creating
scandals or saying crazy things arguably
Paul Ryan maybe helped Romney a little
bit when it comes to the electorate
being from where was Ryan from Virginia
I think Romney being you know a massive
former Massachusetts governor
maybe not didn't really do much one way
or the other Mike Pence didn't do much
for Trump in terms of bad news headlines
he just stayed out of the way but maybe
Pence helped in the Midwest maybe Pence
helped with the evangelical vote which
ultimately mostly went to Donald Trump
anyway I believe if Joe Biden were to
choose Hillary Clinton it would probably
be bad that would probably hurt him if
Joe Biden were to choose you know an
actual Republican if Joe Biden announces
I don't know Ted Cruz is my running mate
I think it's a real problem for Biden I
think that that but obviously he's not
going to do that and if Joe Biden picks
someone with a lot of baggage that can
be attacked that would be a problem so
for example Amy Klobuchar it was
revealed in the aftermath of the killing
of George Floyd that she had been
involved in decisions not to go after
Derek shavon who ultimately is the
officer that killed George Floyd with
the need of the neck once that went
public it was
obvious that Clos Bashar was damaged in
terms of a vice presidential candidate
she came out and said I'm dropping out
because it should be a woman of color
but it was clear at that point she
wasn't going to be selected anyway that
type of baggage could be damaging to Joe
Biden obviously it's not going to be
Clovis Shar now I got a couple emails
from people who said the Native American
thing would be baggage for Elizabeth
Warren I don't know that it would I
really don't know that it would I think
listen if you want to talk about baggage
Kamala Harris is record as California
Attorney General prosecuting the war on
drugs and putting a lot of black folks
in in jail in prison in prison I think
that that may be baggage that Biden does
not need but I may be wrong there so
again the the point here is when you
pick a VP you want someone who's not
going to get a ton of attention because
typically it will be negative attention
number two
you want someone who maybe can help you
in terms of expanding your base of
support and number three you want
someone who's not going to bring some
kind of baggage that is going to
disproportionately become subject matter
for discussion if you disagree with me
let me know we've got a great bonus show
for you today to become a member and get
the bonus show you need only go to join
pakman.com and sign up to exciting
things going on next week Tuesday night
at 8 p.m. Eastern the 3rd David Pakman
show chess tournament it will be at
david pakman.com slash chess you can go
there now and register for free for the
tournament this is all free I'm not
selling anything big shocker to a lot of
people nothing is being sold here just a
community building opportunity david
pakman.com slash chess register for free
tournament 8 p.m. on Tuesday the 14th
number 2 also on Tuesday the 14th we
will be doing a single day membership
special the reason we're doing it is a
sad reason you might think July 14th
what's that what's the deal back in 2019
in early July we did a fourth of July
special hundreds of people signed up all
those memberships came due for renewal a
few days ago and because of the virus
hundreds
those people who signed up in 2019
couldn't afford to renew I got a lot of
email saying I'm sorry David I want to
support you but I can't so we lost
hundreds of members in the first four
days of July not good so we're trying to
counteract that and sort of Rhian
Tuesday we'll do a mailing with a single
day membership special it'll be a
beautiful discount you want to be
notified about it just get on my mailing
list at david pakman.com we will see you
on today's bonus show and then next week